your boy Judas Minister here and Java's
lanyard Travis Kelce here empty on here
Greg Jennings I'm Danny Amendola
hi my name's Pat magazine I'm Emmitt
Smith and we're playing back up a mate
oh say that is a backup say back up stop
this nonsense
sprechen zie th pion gross bitter bitter
made-up football players don't usually
know three languages and that just
doesn't look like a tight end body to me
I'm a tight I'm a body expert so that is
made up for sure made up he's made up
I'm going with made up I don't think he
said to combo record he looks like his
body frame is not built to do this I'm
gonna say made up yeah I'm gonna say
back good I'm gonna go back up I believe
that is a backup I'm already going he's
a backup I think he's a backup that
would be
that's a very sick dude to be a hundred
meter record champion I like the name
kyon though because it's like Dion but
with a keg I'm going made up as made up
the back of his neck is way too big to
be a back prairie view a mm that sounds
like a fake school he should be an
aspiring NFL player if he's just a
rookie nation being aspiring for so I
must've made up right here
but just because what he's real he's
actually a really good receiver son we
going back up I'll just do for sure it's
about go he's a backup I'm gonna say he
is a back dog soon as you said where
you're from I can put the face to the to
the area doubt it offensive line and
played hockey in Texas didn't please
I'll go made up I'm probably wrong here
but I'm gonna go it made up that's made
up
I'd actually played hockey hockey in
Texas is awesome but not the Dallas
Stars happening it's on me
that's a backup here's a backup we'll go
with a backup backup st. cloud the st.
cloud name gave it away he looks happy
he looks like he has a face that wants
to be on camera on YouTube I'm going
with the backup I thought like I was on
still hot start
look I'm terrible look don't get
offended no you didn't know he was the
back yeah you know yes I think he's made
up I believe that is made up made up for
sure I feel like Belichick wouldn't put
up with that having a back or like a
cooking show made up yeah two brothers
in the lead I feel like I would have
heard about it made up that's made up
that's made up I want to Alabam I owe no
heed I made up I guess but I say made up
right that's uh back up that would be a
back up yeah good damn damn damn I'm
embarrassed that I missed that one